und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend man kann es versuchen man kann
klein reden was heute in washington
geschah präsident trump hat ein geheimes
dokument zur veröffentlichung
freigegeben ein protokoll eines
telefongesprächs mit dem neu gewählten
präsidenten der ukraine vor genau zwei
monaten
seitdem versuchen die mitarbeiter und
verbündeten des präsidenten dass dort
gesagte zu einer bagatelle zu erklären
details gleich im bericht von mrt wissen
aber es steht heute zum ersten mal
offiziell das wort impeachment
amtsenthebung überraschung
der grund ist ein vorwurf ohne beispiel
da steht ein präsident unter verdacht
mit einer ausländischen macht verhandelt
zu haben damit sie zu seinen gunsten in
den wahlkampf um das weisse haus
eingreift den nächsten wahlkampf das
wäre so was wie die russland affäre
reloaded nur war trump vor zwei monaten
kein kandidat mehr sondern längst im amt
und das änderte alles
auch die haltung der mächtigsten
demokratin nancy pelosi der sprecherin
des repräsentantenhauses die 1
im pitch montney riskieren wollte aber
jetzt lange hatte nancy pelosi gezögert
aber nun gibt es kein zurück mehr nach
diesen wohl historischen worten die
erkenschwicker mit seinen taten hat
präsident trump verrat begangen an
seinem amtseid an der nationalen
sicherheit und an der integrität unserer
wahl so deuten die demokraten das
telefonat von donald trump mit dem
frisch gewählten präsidenten der ukraine
präsident selensky hatte darin die
amerikanischen militärhilfen
angesprochen ausgerechnet an diesem
punkt bitte donald trump ihn dann um
zitat eingefallen selensky solle auf
ukrainischen computer nach daten über
amerikanischen demokraten suchen lassen
thuram fordert ermittlungen bei der
ehemalige us vizepräsident biden seinen
sohn der geschäfte in der ukraine machte
vor einer korruptions untersuchung
bewahrt haben soll
trump drängt sie lenski die hilfe seines
anwalts julian i und des us
justizministers regelrecht auf tage vor
dem telefonat hatte der us-präsident die
militärhilfen für die ukraine gestoppt
hatte trump einen deal machen schmutzige
informationen über seinen politischen
gegner gegen waffenhilfe beide
teilnehmer des gesprächs bestreiten das
heute sie haben es doch gelesen
niemand hat mich unter druck gesetzt per
los sie wird von der radikalen linken
getrieben sind euch doch die medien
heute an die demokratische partei ist
von den linken wendung
und doch liegt ein hauch von watergate
in der luft richard nixon ließ einst in
das büro der demokratischen partei ein
berechnung schmutz über seine
politischen gegner zu sammeln
1974 führten die öffentlichen anhörungen
des kongresses zu einer fast lückenlose
beweiskette und zum rücktritt des
präsidenten
genau das müsse den demokraten wieder
gelingen um gegen donald trump
erfolgreich zu sein so meint einer der
enthüller des watergate-skandals
präsident an unser land an einen nie
gekannten punkt gebracht indem er eine
fremde macht auffordert unsere freien
wahlen aber am ende brauchen die
demokraten im senat eine
zweidrittel-mehrheit für eine
amtsenthebung mindestens 20 republikaner
müssen sich gegen donald trump enten
kaum vorstellbar sie haben doch die
abschrift des telefonats da ist nichts
was auch nur ansatzweise seine
amtsenthebung recht nancy pelosi weiß
dass sie und ihre demokraten vor allem
die öffentlichkeit überzeugen müssen
bekannt es sei sagt sie eine historische
aufgabe die verfassung der vereinigten
staaten vor allen feinden von außen und
von innen zu schützen und zu schützen
auch vor einem mann im weißen haus über
dessen schicksal falls die amtsenthebung
scheitert am ende die amerikanischen
wähler entscheiden schön und gut aber
wenn dieses telefon protokoll alles ist
eine unterhaltung in der nie deutlich
von einem deal die rede ist militärhilfe
für ermittlungen gegen familie joe biden
wie soll das denn ein im pitch bend
bringen also es gibt hier in washington
den verdacht dass da noch mehr ist zum
einen ist es kein wortprotokoll dieses
telefongespräch sondern nur auszüge
basierend auf notizen also da fehlen
teile
das zweite ist dass der was die
beschwerde des whistleblowers aus den
nachrichtendiensten die dem kongress
eigentlich vorgelegt werden müsste heute
nachmittag an den kongress geht oder
auch da wird erwartet dass teile
geschwärzt worden sind oder fragen sich
hier viele was will diese administration
verbergen deswegen ist so wichtig dass
einerseits ebendieser whistleblower vor
dem kongress aussagen wird
möglicherweise auch schon morgen früh
und zum zweiten auch eben der direktor
der nachrichtendienste morgen vor dem
kongress erscheinen wird
und er soll dort offen aussagen es wird
harte fragen geben weil man vermutet
dass da mehr ist als das was in diesem
protokoll nachzulesen ist haben die
demokraten denn irgendwelche hinweise
darauf dass es ausreicht dass sie am
ende im senat wo trump ja bekanntlich
die mehrheit hat eine zwei drittel
mehrheit gegen ihn aufbringen können
damit die amtsenthebung überhaupt
stattfindet ich glaube da machen sich
die demokraten keine illusionen das ist
extrem unwahrscheinlich auch wenn sie
ein bisschen die hoffnung haben dass die
republikaner sich am ende entscheiden
müssen wenn die beweiskette sehr
eindeutig und überzeugend ist müssen sie
dann sagen ob sie diesen präsidenten des
amtes entheben wollen
tun sie das nicht müssen sie sich im
wahlkampf bei ihrem kampf um die
wiederwahl dafür verantworten und das
ist die große hoffnung der demokraten
dass die beweiskette überzeugend genug
ist um die amerikanische öffentlich
kyte zu überzeugen dass spätestens die
amtszeit von donald trump daneben mit
der wahl oder kurz nach der wahl im
nächsten jahr beendet ist
deutlich spannender wieder gewordenen
washington danke schön und damit zu
deutsche politik in deutschen wäldern
sind nur noch 28 prozent der bäume
gesund fast drei viertel der laub und
nadelbäume sind krank die trockenheit
hat sie anfälliger gemacht zum beispiel
für stürme und borkenkäfer die
bundesregierung verkündete heute ihre
pläne für den deutschen wald es gibt
geld 547 millionen bilder bund zahlen
die länder sollen aufstocken auf 800
millionen euro für neue bäume und mehr
forstarbeiter und auch die jagd soll
zielgerichteter werden damit das wild
die bäume nicht gleich wieder wegfrisst
susanne gelhard berichtet aus der sicht
von leuten die vom wald leben
der ist ja auch ein wirtschaftsgut
millionenfach fallen in diesen wochen
die bäume im deutschen wald besonders
die fichten stürme dürren borkenkäfer
sie haben besonders gelitten
die gefräßige tiere fällen und zerlegen
harvester vollautomatische
erntemaschinen die geschädigten bäume so
wie hier im siegerland bis zu 400 am tag
friedrich von hövel besitzt 1000 hektar
wald die hälfte fichten monokultur für
seine familie ist es die
haupteinnahmequelle seit sechs
generationen
doch jetzt bekommt ihr nur noch die
hälfte für sein holz die kosten
übersteigen die erträge sind die ganzen
funktionen des waldes war noch
gewährleistet indem wir diese großen
kahlflächen haben ist der waldbestand
überhaupt langfristig insgesamt noch
gesichert und wie entwickelt sich das
es ist eine noch nie dagewesene
katastrophe sagt friedrich von hövel
sein käferholz wird per container nach
china verschifft den deutschen
qualitätsstandards genügt es nicht
das ist bitter meint er ein wendepunkt
zeit umzudenken
der wald ist seit jahrhunderten
rohstofflieferant aber auch ein
mächtiges lebenswichtiges ökosystem in
zeiten des klimawandels muss er
geschützt werden
wir brauchen mehr naturnahe
waldwirtschaft sagt gerhard herzog
förster in der eifel einen teil seines
1500 hektar waldes bewirtschaftet er
ganz bewusst nach diesem prinzip
mischwald mit möglichst heimischen arten
behutsam fällen natürliche
waldverjüngung der aufwand ist höher
sagt er dafür das risiko gestreut und
der ertrag kann mit dem anderer betriebe
mithalten
wir haben ein gut sortiertes warenlager
wir haben von allen baumarten was wenn
jetzt wie jetzt im moment die fische
nicht geht dann geht eventuell die eiche
oder douglasien oder die buche und von
daher sind wir sehr flexibel am markt
der deutsche wald braucht vor allem
umdenken meint die waldökologie tanja
sanders und einen umbau differenziert
und regional angepasst statt kahlschlag
die bäume einzeln fällen auch das gehört
dazu
naturnahe waldbewirtschaftung hilft ja
weil wir einfach keine flächige entnahme
haben und so immer wieder baumarten im
schatten der anderen wachsen können
eine selektive entnahme ist aber
natürlich arbeitsintensiver und von
daher auch schwieriger
und da muss in dem sinne auch die
wirtschaft dann sagen gut ich habe dafür
auch einen höheren preis von der
monokultur zu naturnahe waldwirtschaft
ist es ein weiter weg kostenlos ist er
nicht zu haben für das ökosystem wald
ist er zukunft entscheidend professor
pierre giebisch ist biologe und ein
international anerkannter fachmann für
wald und umwelt guten namen professor
ewig guten abend aktiver da wurden jetzt
heute 800 millionen euro versprochen das
ist eine menge geld fließt das auch in
die
wichtigen projekte da bin ich mir auch
nach diesem nationalen weltgipfel noch
nicht ganz sicher weil in der tat immer
wieder angekündigt wird das im
geschädigten wald aufgeräumt werden soll
das sogenannte schadholz beseitigt zu
werden soll um dann im großen stil
wieder aufzuforsten und da ist für mich
nach wie vor die frage ob das der
richtige weg ist was könnte denn der
bessere weg sein
wir haben es zu tun mit dem wald der ist
ein komplexes ökosystem das organisiert
sich selbst reguliert sich selbst wenn
man ist nur lässt und welche ereignisse
da sind nach schweren stürmen nach feuer
oder eben auch jetzt nach der dürre und
insektenfraß ist es ja nicht so dass der
wald dann tot ist sondern der steht
wieder auf es gibt baumarten die auch
spontan einfliegen pionier baumarten
nennen wir die die dann beginnen wieder
so ein ökosystem aufzubauen und ja dafür
hat man aber jetzt keine zeit oder man
hat angst dass das vielleicht die
falschen baumarten sind und deshalb wird
also überwiegend jetzt gesetzt
sicherlich auf aufforsten dann haben wir
es mit einem klimawandel zu tun der in
nie gekannter geschwindigkeit die welt
und damit auch die wälder verändert und
sie plädieren dafür dass einfach in ruhe
zu lassen
der klimawandel muss uns erschrecken und
ganz besonders auch in bezug auf den
wald müssen uns erschrecken wenn jetzt
diese langlebigen organismen tatsächlich
geschädigt werden
aber tatsache ist dass wir wenig wissen
und das gilt für alle wissenschaftler
auch die forstlichen wie der klimawandel
sich entwickelt und wie die ökosysteme
reagieren wie die arten reagieren und
das risiko das gepflanzte baumarten
nicht bestehen ist genauso groß wie das
risiko dass die einheimischen baumarten
die wir versuchen werden das ökosystem
neu zu organisieren dass auch nicht
können
das heißt sie als ein fachmann für diese
fragen speziell für wald sagen die
politik geht im moment blind in
aktionismus in die falsche richtung
ich wünsche mir mehr dialog wie er im
grunde heute auch nicht möglich war im
rahmen des nationalen weltgipfels es war
ein umweltverbände da aber es war
einfach nicht genügend zeit und nicht
genügend raum
es waren auch nicht wissenschaftler die
andere hintergründe haben einbezogen
nicht einbezogen worden und das würde
ich mir doch jetzt wünschen dass dieser
prozess beginnt nun ist ihre stimme im
moment für den normalen zuschauer und
auch journalisten eine einsame stimme im
wald sind sie sich denn mit anderen
fachleuten einig dass diese vorsicht die
sie empfehlen das richtig ist ich bin
nicht der einzige der so denkt und ich
fühle mich bestätigt auch insofern als
dass es nicht nur wissenschaftler sind
die so denken wie ich sondern auch forst
praktiker förster waldbesitzer die
genauso zu der gleichen vorsicht raten
und insofern würde ich mir wünschen dass
ja wir das alles etwas differenzierter
betrachten und uns zeit nehmen für einen
angemessenen dialog kann der deutsche
wald so bleiben wie wir ihn seit
jahrzehnten kennen
er wird nicht so bleiben wir hatten ganz
starke veränderungen sehen und wir
können überhaupt nicht vorhersehen was
passiert wir sind in der jüngsten
vergangenheit überrascht worden
auch von einzelnen baumarten die aus
vielen von dem man das nicht gedacht hat
wir werden auch böse überraschungen
erleben aber ja das ist etwas worauf wir
uns jetzt einstellen müssen was wir
beobachten müssen wo wir aber deshalb
insbesondere auf die
selbstheilungskräfte des wald besetzen
müssen die strukturen fördern die in
kühlen die wasser zurückhalten das sind
eigentlich die entscheidenden
zielstellungen auf die wir jetzt
losgehen müssen
der rat eines fachmanns dankeschön
professor ich danke schön und hier
schließen die nachrichten von gundula
gause lückenlos an
der weltklimarat warnt in seinem neuen
bericht eindringlich vor den folgen des
klimawandels der politik stellen die
wissenschaftler ein verheerendes zeugnis
aus dem bericht nach steigt der
meeresspiegel doppelt so schnell wie im
vergangenen jahrhundert ganze
küstenstreifen könnten unbewohnbar
werden
der weltklimarat rechnet deswegen mit
bis zu 280 millionen flüchtlingen und
warnt vor immer extremeren
wetterkatastrophen stürme und hochwasser
30 jahre nach der wende sieht die
bundesregierung deutliche fortschritte
beim wirtschaftlichen aufholprozess in
den ostdeutschen ländern
so hätten die löhne inzwischen etwa 84
prozent des westniveaus erreicht erklärt
der ostbeauftragte hirte
zugleich warnt er viele ostdeutsche
fühlten sich nach wie vor als bürger
zweiter klasse seien angesichts der
umbrüche durch digitalen wandel und
migration veränderungs müde
die linke kritisierte die deutsche
einheit komme auf vielen gebieten nur im
schneckentempo voran
die deutsche bischofskonferenz hat das
zu beratende bessere system zur
entschädigung von missbrauchsopfern
grundsätzlich bestätigt die konkrete
höhe der zahlungen müsse allerdings noch
geklärt werden erklärten der
missbrauchsbeauftragte der konferenz
bischof ackermann und der sprecher der
opfervereinigung eckiger tisch matthias
katsch zwei modelle werden diskutiert
eines sieht eine pauschale entschädigung
von rund 300.000 euro pro fall vor das
andere ein abgestuftes verfahren je nach
schwere zwischen 40.000 und 400.000 euro
gut eine woche nach der wahl in israel
hat staatspräsident rägelin den
bisherigen ministerpräsidenten netanjahu
mit der bildung einer neuen regierung
beauftragt harte koalitionsverhandlungen
sind zu erwarten denn netanjahus
konkurrent ex generalstabschef ganz
stellt mit seiner liste einen
abgeordneten mehr als der
rechtskonservative likud von netanjahu
irans präsident rooney will weiterhin
nicht mit den usa verhandeln solange
diese an ihren sanktionen festhalten
in seiner rede vor der
un-vollversammlung appellierte er an
us-präsident trump sich wieder an die
verpflichtungen des atomdeals zu halten
erst dann sei iran zu gesprächen bereit
die geduld seines landes habe grenzen
erklärte rooney
iran werde entschlossen und stark auf
provokationen von ausländern reagieren
es erschien als ein triumph des
rechtsstaats gestern als der britische
supreme court den zwangsurlaub des
parlamentes organisiert von boris
johnson für null und nichtig erklärte
die strenge lady mit der spinnen branche
sprach von der vornehmen aufgabe des
parlaments volkswillen durchsetzen
regierung kontrollieren was sich dann
heute im wieder versammelten parlament
abspielte bild zu diesem hohen anspruch
nicht so recht passen nach wie vor gibt
es keine mehrheit für irgendeine lösung
es war viel los und nix kamen dabei raus
außer dass boris johnson seinen briggs
it weiter durchzieht will ein anderes
parlament verdient heute mehr
aufmerksamkeit österreich welt am
sonntag ein neues parlament dass
sebastian kurz wie der kanzler wird
steht mittlerweile praktisch fest die
frage ist mit wem
doch wieder mit der fpö deren chef sich
und seine partei auf ibiza unmöglich
machte britta hilpert über einen
wahlkampf der mit schmutz begannen und
so auch endet das fg oktoberfest
kürzlich war sehr unbeschwert neuer
parteichef umfragewerte bei 20 prozent
nicht nur sie auch hc strache dachte
wohl die visa-affäre lägen nun hinter
ihnen
er taucht hier überraschend auf
es tue so gut unter leuten zu sein sagt
er seinem nachfolger norbert hofer zu
dem zeitpunkt aber ist der nächste
strache skandal bereits im anrollen
ermittlungen wegen veruntreuung von
partei spesen 10.000 euro im monat und
mehr ein enger strache mitarbeiter hat
wohl ausgepackt vom
selbstbedienungsladen spd sprechen sogar
parteimitglieder schuld sei aber ein
netzwerk von außen und dieses netzwerk
hat das ziel die freiheitliche partei
österreichs schwer zu schädigen ja man
kann sogar sagen zu vernichten
der wahlkampf beginnt schmutzig und
endet so das sogenannte e bis a video
brach der fpö chef strache und dann die
ganze regierung kurz zu fall
nun wird jeder jedem vor nicht sauber zu
sein jeder klagt über schmutzkübel
kampagne der gegner so auch die kurz
partei cvp
erst berichtet die zeitung falter über
nicht ganz vorschriftsmäßig schreddern
von festplatten des kanzleramtes über
die kreative buchführung des vp
wahlkampfs doch die kurz partei sagt bei
einem hacker angriff seien daten
verfälscht worden experten bestätigen
den hack die manipulation noch nicht
trotzdem meint der parteichef
dieser angriff was sicherlich ein
angriff auf die volkspartei aber auch
ein angriff auf unsere demokratie weil
er ja ein klares ziel hat nämlich mit
gestohlenen und verfälschten
informationen den wahlkampf in
österreich zu beeinflussen
sebastian kurz liegt in umfragen weit
fahren aber er hatte schon mehr als die
rund 35 prozent jetzt er braucht einen
partner der villigster und
programmatische nächste ist der alte
aber die fpö ist skandal erschüttert
instabil und umgelegt würden wir jetzt
unterstellen dass sebastian kurz gerne
eine fortsetzung der bisherigen
koalition anstrebt müsste er dennoch
zuerst eigentlich mit den anderen
parteien verhandeln um einfach zu zeigen
dass es versucht hat ist der reis
bundespräsidenten ist wohl klar
diese war begeistert wahrlich nicht alle
schmutzkübel absehbares koalitions
gerangel ein video soll motivieren
trotzdem
wählen am sonntag und 17 uhr wissen wir
mehr
jetzt wissen wir auch mehr als vorhin
das britische parlament tagt der
unverdrossen weiter und da hat
offensichtlich boris johnson gerade
erklärt dass er eine neue rede der queen
mit seinem regierungsprogramm ansetzen
wolle und dazu gehört üblicherweise ein
zwangsurlaub des parlaments das heißt es
steht jetzt im raum in westminster das
dasselbe nochmal versucht wird so hat
das allerdings noch nicht gesagt
nachrichten nun aus der wirtschaft nach
dem britischen reisekonzern thomas cook
haben heute auch die deutsche und die
österreichische tochter insolvenz
angemeldet betroffen sind deutsche
kunden von neckermann reisen öger tours
air marin und bucher reisen wir fragen
nach frankfurt valerie haller
was müssen diese kunden nun wissen also
keine panik das rät zumindest die
insolvenzversicherung den betroffenen
wer eine reise gebucht und eine
anzahlung geleistet hat der soll eine
entschädigung bekommen und war gerade
unterwegs ist mit thomas cook der soll
zurückgebracht werden ob aber das geld
das für den insolvenzschutz vorgesehen
ist reicht das ist jetzt die grosse
frage der veranstalter verkauft schon
seit montag keine reisen mehr auch sind
alle anstehenden trips zunächst bis
morgen auf eis gelegt durch den
insolvenzantrag der deutschen thomas
cook springt jetzt also die versicherung
ein
97000 kunden sind derzeit noch mit
thomas cook im urlaub weitere 660.000
haben reisen gebucht und zumindest schon
eine anzahlung geleistet die
versicherungssumme ist allerdings auf
110 millionen euro gedeckelt und die
teilen sich womöglich hunderttausende
urlauber am ende könnte die
entschädigung sehr dürftig ausfallen
für großinsolvenzen wie die von thomas
cook ist das reise insolvenzrecht
einfach nicht geschaffen eine änderung
wurde zwar angemahnt kam politisch aber
nicht voran
für thomas cook deutschland und seine
kunden hängt nun viel davon ab ob das
unternehmen einen staatlichen
überbrückungskredit bekommt auch für die
rund 2.000 mitarbeiter die jetzt um
ihren job bangen
viele dank valerie ich nach frankfurt
nach vier jahren bauzeit haben die
chinesen bei peking den neuen flughafen
daxing eröffnet der gebäudefläche nach
ist es der größte airport der welt auf
700.000 quadratmetern die konstruktion
wird wegen ihrer form auch bei seestern
genannt der flughafen soll zum
internationalen drehkreuz werden und
später bis zu 100 millionen passagiere
im jahr abfertigen
die eröffnung gelang pünktlich wenige
tage vor den feiern zum siebzigsten
jahrestag der gründung der volksrepublik
der alternative nobelpreis geht in
diesem jahr an vier aktivisten die sich
für den schutz von klima menschenrechten
und indigenen völkern engagieren
die bekannteste unter ihnen greta
thunberg die 16 jährige schwedin habe
der politischen forderung nach
klimaschutzmaßnahmen weltweit gehör
verschafft so die right livelihood
stiftung
außerdem werden die menschenrechtlerin
haidar aus der westsahara und die
chinesische frauen rechtsanwältin geehrt
sowie der brasilianische ureinwohner
kommunalwahl der sich für den schutz
seines stammes der yanomami im
amazonasgebiet einsetzt
es fehlen noch die gewinnzahlen vom
lotto am mittwoch
sie lauten diesmal wie immer ohne gewähr
57 15 23 33 37 superzahl 8 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text wenn man diesen herren fragt was er
beruflich macht bezeichnet er sich als
bastler das ist so nettes understatement
wie er aussieht davon darf man sich
nicht täuschen lassen in wirklichkeit
ist tom sechs künstler der sich seine
werke zusammenbastelt aber er ist alles
andere als harmlos net das hat die
kunstwelt spätestens verstanden als er
ein kz nach baute in einer
schuhschachtel von prada das ist dann
alles schon ein bisschen vertrackter und
haariger mit ihm sonst wäre er wohl auch
nicht zu internationaler anerkennung
kommen als könig der ricola
das zusammenbasteln das schauwerk
sindelfingen widmet dem amerikaner
gerade eine bemerkenswerte ausstellung
soll bei frick war dort der künstler
jagen und sammeln ist nur allzu
menschlich was gefunden im kunst zu
machen ist dagegen zivilisation der
amerikaner tom sykes hat das
perfektioniert sein werk besteht aus dem
suchen und finden er ist ein meister des
bricolage specials ist meine spezialität
ist das basteln basteln bedeutet bauen
und reparieren
mit den zur verfügung stehenden
ressourcen alles was sie hier sehen ist
mit gefundenen dingen gemacht
das herzstück der ausstellung ist die
teezeremonie bezogen auf ein uraltes
japanisches ritual in dem ein schritt
streng auf den nächsten folgen muss in
drei großen räumen steht jede
installation für eine persönliche
erfahrung von tom sex alles baut
aufeinander auf wie bei der teezeremonie
für sex ein sehr persönliches werk
das ist auch meine teezeremonie das
wichtigste an diesem brauch der
teezeremonie ist die erneuerung und die
anpassung an eine situation in der man
sich befindet
dadurch wird es zu einer sehr
persönlichen erfahrung welche
persönliche erfahrungen der künstler mit
flugzeugtoiletten gemacht hat wissen wir
nicht aber es ist eine originalgetreue
nachbildung der ja nur ein fake echte
fälschung die sex ist nennt
künstlerische das erschaffen ist ein
ritual und die belohnung für gute arbeit
ist noch mehr arbeit
es dauert monate und immer passiert
alles gleichzeitig zu befruchten sich
die ideen gegenseitig ich löse ein
problem durch ein anderes rituale und
zeremonien prägen sachs wortschatz sein
leben und die kunst sind für ihn ein
hochamt
zentrales element ist das wasser das
wasser des lebens am ende gesammelt in
einer schale t6 hat dabei einen durchaus
selbstironischen bezug zu seiner
sammelleidenschaft
hier sehen sie meine ersten 100 versuche
mein kabinett der verlierer
das bin ich wie ich lerne denn mein
privileg als künstler ist es mich selbst
zu erziehen und mich dabei zu
unterhalten
und während das hier meine fehler sind
das sind meine helden vom sex werk
handelt vom suchen und finden der
schönheit von der perfektion im
unperfekten und von der kunst das beste
draus zu machen
diese ausstellung geht noch bis ende
april auf unser journal folgt das
auslandsjournal unter anderem mit einem
bericht aus saudi arabien da kommt man
als journalist nicht so ohne weiteres
rein
die kollegin isabel kimmina ist gerade
von dort zurück ihre eindrücke
also gleich das gesamte norden
[Musik]
meine damen und herren das tief von
morgen heißt lisa und die sander zieht
über die britischen inseln weiter
richtung mitteleuropa
es leitet eine phase beim wetter ein wo
es wirklich abwechslungsreich ist auch
in dieser nacht ist es abwechslungsreich
im westen fällt regen im osten bildet
sich hier nebel und dieser nebel bei 14
bis 8 grad der muss ich morgen vormittag
erstmal auflösen dann aber sehen sie
dort auch hin und wieder die sonne und
auch am alpenrand werden sie morgen
vormittag noch mal kurz die sonne sehen
können während der regen von
tieffliegern da weiter nach osten zieht
und am späten nachmittag oder frühen
abend schleswig holstein erreicht auch
den harz den thüringer wald den
oberpfälzer und den bayerischen wald der
wind dazu kommt meist aus südlichen
richtungen ist zum teil auch mal etwas
stärker und die temperaturen steigen auf
15 grad an den alpen und bis 21 grad in
magdeburg oder in der lausitz und auch
rund um berlin wird es recht mild
es geht sehr wechselhaft bei uns weiter
das sehen sie hier am vor schaufeln bis
zum wochenende
da kommt ein tief hinter dem anderen her
und vor allen dingen über
norddeutschland sie diese regenwolken im
süden bleibt es deutlich freundlicher
und das zeigt sich natürlich auch bei
unseren drei tage aussichten da sehen
sie am freitag in süddeutschland im
sonnenschein bei temperaturen bis 24
grad im norden und osten gibt es dagegen
regenschauer und so ähnlich sieht es am
wochenende auch weiterhin aus schönen
abend noch